hi I'm Erik Bosse and as we dig up more
and more clues about Avengers in Game
one Thanos survivor who carries the big
mystery with them is this little trash
Panda Rocket Raccoon and I don't tell
him I called him a raccoon he hates that
it's because his exact Anatomy his
origin his creator remain unknown
James Gunn hinted way back that a major
easter egg regarding Rockets creator is
hidden somewhere in volume 2 but no one
has officially found it recently someone
on reddit may be someone really really
really smart enough started to dig into
this question so I'm gonna explain what
new things we've learned and some new
details about rocket discovered from
guardians volume to and from adventures
in game footage it's okay let's rewind
the clock to November 2017 when
guardians volumes 1 & 2 director James
Gunn tweeted back before the hoards
vidiots drove him off Twitter that the
truth about Rockets creator was hidden
somewhere in volume 2 ever since then
the hunt was on actually much of the
focus was on the still missing Easter
egg in volume 1 we actually made a video
about it James Gunn tweeted us some nice
things but it's still wrong in the past
he's actually said that youtuber MT a
really sharp fella if I say so myself
has gotten closest but this rocket
mystery forces us to look at some
different evidence the first guardians
movie gave us a few details hinted at
Rockets origin remember as the guardians
were processed ons and are the screen
said that his homeworld was half world
which is Rockets origin in the Marvel
Comics half world is an abandoned colony
where mentally ill animal companions are
genetically manipulated to be more
human-like rocket was one of these and
he's given human intelligence and served
as a security officer the screen in that
zantar scene also lists anatomical
features cybernetic skeletal structure
enhanced Falange and metacarpal bones as
are the hands and feet
genetically augmented cerebral cortex
and later in the kiln quill sees these
surgical scars of rockets cybernetic
skeleton on his back later rocket growls
about his past saying this right after
this another possible clue shows up in
the collectors vault on know where
Rockets stood beside a table with an
animal spine that
small enough to belong to a raccoon some
believe that this could mean the
collector could have been Rockets
creator rocket could have been an
escaped experiment one of the many
prized possessions of the collector and
that spine could have been Rockets old
spine before it was replaced with a
cybernetic one but before we get too
ahead of ourselves James Gunn himself
debunked this theory yeah unless his
memory was wiped or something there's no
way rocket wouldn't immediately attack
this old dr. Frankenstein and that
brings us to volume 2 which upon
re-watching it does contain some
interesting nods to Rockets backstory
when they were escaping the sovereign
fleet rocket Pickers with quill and says
this later rocket orgy's with gandu and
this comes up remind you how big and
empty that hole inside you actually I
said shut up I know them scientists what
made you never give a rat's ass about
you I'm serious this actually echoes
another rant in volume 2 from a
character who was weaponized with
cybernetic implants nebula she rages
that they nose severed parts of her body
and replaced them with parts every time
Gamora beat her in a sparring match so
could rocket be another long-lost child
of Bannos an infinity war rocket did
seem to want to go nowhere near Thanos
until he could help Thor get his hands
on a weapon to kill the mad Titan he
would think rocket would have said
something about his history with Thanos
maybe he's just keeping his backstory
close to the chest
but think about it for this theory to be
true it would have required some
collaboration between James Gunn and the
filmmakers of the Guardians movies and a
filmmakers behind infinity war an
endgame it's two separate camps even
though the whole operation is overseen
by Kevin Feige I don't think these two
movies are all written that closely
together and there's one third possible
theory for Rockets creator that I want
to talk about but first
thanks to morning brew for sponsoring
this video morning brew is a free daily
newsletter that breaks down everything
you need to know about the business
world in a quick 5-minute read because
let's face it business news is usually
pretty dense dry boring doesn't have to
be that way though since I began
subscribing to morning brew they've
delivered the latest business news from
Wall Street Silicon Valley directly
my inbox and it's written in this witty
and conversational tone I get it now
it makes reading this news actually
enjoyable you can get smarter in just
five minutes get all the most relevant
updates and then get on with your day
join one million others who are already
in the know and start your day with
morning brew just click on the link in
the description below to sign up for
free ok back to this third possibility
for rockets creator this theory comes
from a reddit post by user sorrow cron
and really it's the reason a lot of us
aren't talking about this rocket mystery
again this user reminded us how one of
the bombshell theories for the missing
Easter egg and volume one was connected
to the coordinates of the various
locations that show up throughout the
film all these coordinates to have
letters and numbers in them but if you
swap out the numbers for the
corresponding alphabet letters you get
secret messages pointing to quills
mother Meredith quill
so this reddit user applied this to the
coordinates throughout volume 2 coming
up with a number of codes depending on
whether you group certain letters
together and so far these codes just
seem like random letters gibberish but
combined together they do kind of look
short enough to be words of a sentence
or a phrase but this reddit post also
brought up another set of Easter eggs
from volume 2 when they escaped the
Ravagers ship rocket flips through a few
planets on a tablet screen and reversing
the screen you can see the first three
planet names rez Lara Paula
that's the Kree planet that will you see
in Captain Marvel and terma
now these planets show up in the comic
dilation conquest across the prevent
that features regarding the galaxies
quasars moon dragon Adam warlock much
others and the first issue features the
Marvel character the High Evolutionary
so the High Evolutionary is Herbert
Windham he's a geneticist who
experimented on animals and created the
new men which was a group of animals
that he transformed into these proto
human forms not too far away from what
rock it is even though in the comics see
something very different over the course
of the Marvel comics the High
Evolutionary runs into the x-men Spider
Woman the Inhumans a bunch of other
characters it actually be a pretty
interesting villain for phase 4
but if James Gunn intended on bringing
High Evolutionary into the Guardians
storyline of volume 3 the High
Evolutionary could be a very plausible
source of rockets cybernetic implants in
the Cinematic Universe actually when
watching that part of volume 2 two more
planets show up on rocket screen of
course ego there
nation but before that Tara aka earth
and we should also consider the
possibility that rocket came from Earth
back when he could have just been a
raccoon
before he was enhanced perhaps when
rocket and Thor arrived in Wakanda an
infinity war
this wasn't Rockets first time on this
planet like we do see him in that end
game footage wearing the blue button up
jumpsuit that rocket where's the
Guardians comics so maybe this change of
clothes was from some past experience on
this planet no you know what I'm gonna
open up the search to you guys let us
sleuth out the missing rocket Easter Egg
together three watch guardians volume
two with me and anything new that you
come up with tweet it to new rock stars
with the hashtag sleuth squad squad
goals sleuthing clues comment below with
your thoughts follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at a loss and subscribe to
this channel and subscribe to our
podcast where we listen podcasts and if
you happen to live in the LA area please
come out my live nerdy comedy show
darkest timeline comedy every first
Friday of the month at Acme comedy
theater in North Hollywood James Gunn if
you're watching this please come and be
a guest thanks for watching and akin her
hashtag is sleuth squad and that what my
first pick was Rocket daddies it just
sounds weird and I'm not gonna you know
encourage that phrase but if it catches
on I guess hi I'm Eric buzz is getting a
little tired too hi I'm rocking
[Music]